The first thing what you do is this conversation.
You split this into the different conversations that have been had during this conversation.
Now this audio can be about that project.
Yeah, anyway.
And then the extra content you put with your project.
This is for example like a quick overview I think of the stuff.
It's the flow that it should be doing.
I think you should describe that but not in your sales piece.
Describe how it works.
That's for example here.
Phase one.
AI first line support.
AI reads incoming tickets automatically, answers simple questions immediately, attempts
to fix known issues, only escalates complex problems to humans.
For complex issues AI creates detailed tickets with problem description, how to reproduce
system info suggested solution and routes to right human agent.
System learns from resolved tickets, gets smarter over time, identifies problems.
That one happens because the whole background gets better.
The agent how do you say what you're having.
Hey we're setting up this workflow for you.
This is going to be working.
This is going to help Jacqueline to be able to deal with additional load to see what we
get.
This one will improve the quality.
So Jacqueline spends most of her time organizing and prioritizing tickets right?
Yes, a lot of that.
And a lot of that will be done by this one already.
The thing is this one will do already initial triage as they knew because sometimes you
how do you say you can resolve a problem already in five minutes but because you're only the
next day picking up the tickets it's always going to take a day.
So if somebody has a quick question it will never ask that.
At some moment you can integrate that with the frequent asked questions and what so ever
and have a really smart AI what so ever.
Or if you have a frequent asked question whatever that gets a complicated one that it actually
routes it to this one.
Because this one is more for development this is like support this is not question.
And for example key requirements must have any workflow automation, AI ticket classification,
auto response for simple issues, human escalation for complex issues, integration with existing
ticketing system.
But nice to have would be staff training, knowledge based setup and like a dashboard
or something like that is like useless.
Because they have a ready ticketing system for that one.
So staff training would be nice to have.
Staff training is from how this works.
When you put a special price, a separate price on it.
So you have like this is the normal price for the product.
This one is for training sessions.
Like half day training sessions where you put for example.
And then they can see how many they want.
Ok now this timeline I set 4 weeks you set 2 weeks.
For the one from Jacqueline.
For this ticketing system.
For the ticketing system actually how do you say that one can take longer because that
one has more how you call that.
It's a workflow that we need to figure out still.
What?
The one from the ticketing because the one that you have there is too simplified because
it's not just.
Yeah but this those two end to end projects they go together.
They are two different ones.
So I need to make two proposals.
Yes.
Actually you should have said that sooner.
No I have said that.
I read your emails back.
Huh?
Read my replies back.
I have replying that to you.
I was making that dramatic.
Hey there is also another one.
You're forgetting the other one.
There are like there are several proposals that you are going to be making in principle.
This is for the first time from there to ah you did tell me.
So tell me.
Okay so.
You know what I was talking to mom the Wednesday morning whatever and I was to mom hey honey
you know what is the main insight.
Yeah yeah yeah.
You know what is the main takeaway from this whole conversation.
Yeah yeah just wait a minute.
You know what is the main insight is people should start listening to me instead of criticizing
and whatsoever you know.
And mom saying the whole time yeah yeah whatever I'm busy or whatever having my massage here
I'm on the phone here whatsoever.
And why does nobody tell me?
No nobody tells you.
You don't listen.
That's the same as the table.
You're mixing my content already.
Anyway so you have how do you say the workflow one yeah is actually a complete work out process
already.
It's in the whole CI CD pipeline we have feedback how do you say it's a completely fine feedback
loop but it needs to be automated.
At this moment we need to kick in prompt by prompt by prompt and that is just output from
the build process can be can be directly fed into the next process to run.
Did you get what I'm saying there?
I didn't listen to the last part honestly because I was like what?
So the end on the development side yeah that is an already established process.
We know what we need to do.
Yeah.
The only thing that needs to be done is the prompts that I already prepared that are already
prepared for N8N.
All of those things are already there.
They need to be implemented doing it in N8N.
It should be the easiest one to set up.
That one has also the biggest value.
I'm going to try to do all my questions quick so I can just go home and finish up this and
I can send it today already.
I need to make two proposals.
One is for the N8N.
I'm not sure if it should be two maybe it should be more.
Again you have also that training whatsoever.
It's from hey after we've done this one we can train you how to do this in a very efficient
way.
You have seen that we will deliver this one in a two week time frame.
We can teach you to do the same.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
My question is can you describe more accurately what is the first N8N project and what is the
second N8N project?
There are two projects.
The first one is that will help with the triage and the first line help support.
And that AI agent that gets that information in should have how do you say the result of
that one should be that Jacqueline has less things to work on, less things to do.
Many tickets that are currently coming in, Karine needs to figure out who's going to
do that one and the only thing what we are doing is we are copying that one straight
into cursor and fix everything straight away from start to finish.
How do you say there will be some things where this cannot be having complex tickets?
Complex tickets yes we can do that one, yes it can go through it but that one needs to
have a stronger review.
That is like the review cycle of the thing because this is not just classifying a ticket
and whatsoever.
No, this is the full flow that actually already fixes the ticket because that is what we are
doing.
I'm just copying the content, the logging or whatever from the cursor in, I'm just copying
it in and it just gives me the answer already.
So I'm not needed here.
But that whole process drags everything down in speed at this moment.
Now, by just how to say sometimes a fix is so easy that this one hey this is wrong spell
and whatsoever, that is something, you know, quick easy things.
They can be done almost automatically if not completely automatically.
But that means also, automatically means also that it does, how do you say, it makes
a fix but it also commits the fix as the whole description of the fix and whatsoever.
And then it's still from okay when do we apply this fix or where do we apply this fix.
All of that one, the branching and whatsoever, all of that pre-work can be done already by
AI.
So you are only what you need to do is that last final step review whatever yes this makes
sense, build and deliver.
And the second project?
The second project is when we have a certain software made, it has a certain build pipeline
that it goes through.
Now that build pipeline I set up already.
Part of that build pipeline is how you say you get a certain results back, you get certain
quality reports back.
Based on those quality reports you can start up the next and it ends cycle that runs through
the next one.
So you, I have prompts, I get every report back and I prompt, hey run this prompt on
this one, that makes the plan to fix it, makes the fix, executes those plans, makes the fixes,
commits the, now I'm committing those fixes, compile again, get the new report.
And you cycle, cycle, cycle.
Can you explain that one better?
The, how do you say, you have for example, you have is everything documented?
It says from hey, this and this class is not documented, this function is not documented,
it's all in the report.
So after the build you can put that straight to the, how do you say, to the process to
fix documentation.
Hey, based on this result, run this prompt, make the documentation.
So the second and it ends workflow is essentially, so every git repository is correctly documented.
Documented, unit tested, crap score fixed, if it has license problems, is it, is a whole
chain of...
I need to know exactly what things you need to fix.
The thing, it creates a report, yeah, and based on the, there's like, we are not doing
any errors, warnings, and that's it for now.
So all the warnings that it gets, yeah, there is already a process when, give me those warnings
based on the output of that one, what processes do I need to start to show, which prompt do
I need to run, and it will run those prompts away.
And that process is already there, but it's going to be a manual process, and with NNN
it should become an automatic process.
Yeah, I don't know if NNN can run prompts, but it definitely can.
You can run an agent, an agent is a, the prompt is the agent, and then your in and output
is the file that you're running.
But then that would mean you have to do so many agents for every single one of the prompts.
Sorry, there?
No, no.
Or one agent has all the prompts.
One, no, you have multiple, you will probably have multiple agents, which has to run.
Yeah, but that's the thing, do you want to make an NNN work with 60 agents?
If that is, how do you say, if one agent...
What I mean is just that is more complicated, that will take more than two weeks.
No, it doesn't.
Because what you do is, hey, for the, create me the script and whatsoever, or the Python
script and whatsoever, that makes from this, how do you say, from this prompt, converts
that it starts and runs as an agent, doing blah, blah, blah.
You're creating the process to make these types of things.
Eva is already working on that.
You don't do those things for my little girl.
Anyways, I will try to have the proposal for today, later, like after midday, probably.
Yeah, yeah.
But the process is in an automated flow.
Eva actually has already the cursor instances with all the prompts in it that do that flow.
Just to clarify again, it would be nice to have, like what to deliver is a short documentation
with executive summary, what the project does, what the...
What the project gives you, what you're going to improve on that, what you're going to accelerate
with that.
Yeah, but I need...
Yeah, so you have three, you have basically three accelerators.
One is the accelerator for Jacqueline.
The other accelerator is for the build workflow, so the quality goes up automatically.
And the third one is to accelerate Energy 21 to start learning to do these things.
Yeah, those are where it accelerates.
No, but I want to know.
All of those.
Yeah, I know.
Executive summary.
Yeah.
What the project is.
Wait, what the project is.
Then you have how much it costs, what it accelerates for you, what does it solve?
For you, you say solve, I say accelerate because it's...
What the project accelerates for you.
Yeah, because that is what is going to, how do you say, that is the only thing that matters
is how much faster are we going to be.
What can one person do instead of, you know, now the person start having time again and
now the person is not overrun.
Now the people stop doing robot work.
Yeah, yeah, what can be automated?
It's not robots are going to leave us without work, it's we are doing robot work.
Yeah, and stop doing that.
Yes.
Anyways, I do get it.
Anyways, and then apart from that short description, short everything, you want a more detailed
proposal with...
I think, how do you say, it doesn't have to have a lot of blue.
This is what I need to be present to Gaston.
Yes, but I need to know what they're expecting, what is the quality you're expecting, what
is the format you're expecting.
How do you say...
It would be so easy if I had a previous proposal for example.
Yeah, I don't have that one.
And the thing is, I had to say, this is one initial one with Gaston.
And the problem that is here is that you are family.
But there's also the solution, that's why I know you will be able to do this.
I know we can pull this off.
It's a nice start showing them your quality and that teaching and whatsoever, hey, if
we need to be in Europe, then if we need to fly and whatsoever on short notice, how
do you say, transport and accommodation is arranged by Volanto whatsoever, or we arrange
it and then it will be about this price.
Yep.
But it could, how do you say, add it to the proposal one.
For me it should be like a short one from Gaston.
Yeah, honestly, traveling at this moment is going to be expensive, but not because the
plane tickets are expensive.
It's because I have, I'm starting, it's very inconvenient for me, but I will do it.
It will cost more.
Anyway, but the thing is, how and what are you going to be, how do you say, it's a document
that I can offer to Gaston and where Gaston can say this is fair, this is not extreme,
don't do that, just from hey, this is a fair price.
No, that's why I asked you because I was already like.
No, how do you say, what I mean is with this one, if you make in two weeks this amount
of money, you're running positive.
That is what I mean.
You're making already more than what.
Yeah.
At that moment you can already start thinking, okay.
And then after that we already have good, how do you say, good propaganda.
We were able to pull this off.
If you do, right, and what's the matter, blah, blah, blah, all those things.